i'm not alone in thinking this and i
think it's totally
unacceptable look at the nba nfl
and the other leagues they've already
implemented these things
and now we are we are vaccinated and
we're still going to be trapped in a
prison
and i can talk about myself being a
bipolar one it's been hard
i'm not saying it's hard for me anyone
else but one of the biggest things for
being bipolar
they tell you not to do is isolation
self-isolation i've tried to figure out
a way for me to as good as possible
perform which i have done
it doesn't mean that i've been doing
good personally and i
i'm not perfect i've you know it's been
hard
but i'm not talking just about myself
here's for everyone we
you know we have kids we uh you look at
schools you look at kids mental health
you see
you for christ's sakes you see 10 12 11
year olds
talking about suicide committing suicide
all that stuff
the mental health impact in the world is
going to be shown over the next three to
five years and those statistics are not
just on who kills themselves for
committing suicide right now
i had suicides in my family i know what
it's
about
people people develop things during
isolations like this like drug abuse
domestic violence financial issues that
cause
bad anxiety leads to depression all
these things the
traumatic stress div leads to bipolar
and all that type of things
so a lot of these things we might not
see today in statistics but we'll see it
three to five years exactly what's
happening and i'm not saying
not focus don't focus on kobe we have to
of course but if you're vaccinated and
we have
good doctors around us we're we're in
the nhl we have some of the best doctors
around us too that keeps telling us
the statistics when you're vaccinated
all these types of things
some point we got to start looking at
the mental health of people around us
not just
nhl but everyone in society and see how
can we start getting back to normalcy
because the problem is going to be huge
but being lied to us about things
changing to before
kind of forced us to take the vaccine
unacceptable and to now when we have
taken the backs team to have an excuse
of saying
nah it's not we're not changing
because of competitive advantage it's
outrageous